foreign
[Music]
the title of my talk is demystifying
creating custom libraries for your own
organization
and just like a lot of our talks we like
to go with long titles so I don't know
if mine like wins the long title haven't
counted it out yet but um but yeah so
you know when I was thinking about this
talk I was thinking
you know libraries feel like they're
like reserved for more developers and
there's this you know tough thing that
you know it's it's super difficult you
have to read many chapters and what I
found in my journey it's not and this
talk could actually be two minutes
instead of 20 minutes
um but just to hit the requirements I
put a bunch of fluff in this no no I'm
kidding there there's some good stuff
here
um so just going forward you know my
hopes from this presentation is that you
guys all get inspired you know Inspire
to you know create your own libraries
and you know Inspire other people on
your team to contribute to those
libraries and those packages
you know before we jump in like let's do
a little introduction of myself my name
is Dan Kaley my hobbies are hiking and
taking care of my dog helmet that's him
in a little vests I was hoping for a
little bit more oohs and Oz when
everyone saw my dog but
I'll I'll uh whatever we'll we'll talk
after
um I work at CustomInk as a senior data
analyst and I CustomInk what we do is we
create custom t-shirts for organizations
and so we do that because we're trying
to build community and bring people
together you know just like this
conference when we got that R Studio
t-shirt we're all you know 20 of the
people here aren't wearing it and it's
bringing us all together and and this
company was founded in 2001 and I swear
to you all of these people here look
just the same and it's 2022. so if you
ever work at CustomInk they might have
discovered immortality I haven't
confirmed it yet
um and this is you know this idea of
bringing us together from like a
community perspective is kind of the
same thing about libraries you know we
all love these libraries we get involved
we want to contribute and there's a
little bit of community
um and so yeah so like
you know that's you know the kind of the
theme of a library or a package at its
at its uh core
so the things that we're going to cover
is you know why package your functions
in the library because that's what a
library is it's just a bunch of
functions you know and we're just going
to briefly talk about functions
um and how to create a function and then
create a library and then document in
your function and then how to install
your library and how to install your
library is going to be the important
part because that's going to allow you
to uh share it either via GitHub through
you know your github's firewall or you
know you can have it saved in a local
directory
so yeah so you know why package your
function Library if you've um if you've
ever had this internal internal thought
process you know where did I save that
function again like you're building
something you create this cool function
and you're like hey I want to use that
function again but where did I say that
where did I put it what file like what
folder did I delete it oh my gosh that's
like a that's scary you know you know
why can't I find this function and you
start spiraling you know what did I do
did I save it in a notepad and our
markdown did I print it out and then fax
it to myself like you're going you're
going south you know
um
you know I'll just rewrite the function
you know it takes you 30 minutes an hour
two hours again to rewrite it and so
this is the idea of like packaging your
code is that you want to take those
functions package them up so that
they're already in your R environment
and then you could just load them up and
then use them and then also to allow
your co-workers to use them and Inspire
them and maybe they're having the same
problems or maybe they didn't realize
that they could create a function like
that because they're just so busy
um
so yeah so I'm just going to skip
through this part
so let's just cover what a function is
real fast
so a function is a set of a set of
statements that when combined performs a
specific task
so an example that we're going to use
we're going to use this function for the
uh when we build our package so we're
going to build a not in function So for
anybody who use SQL there's an in and a
not in and the in function you know
filters on a list of values not in does
the opposite
and that's nice because let's say you
have like a lifts a list of 20 things
and you want to exclude only two of them
you don't want to list out 18 you only
want to list the two so you can include
the 18. so in order to create that
function all we're going to do and it's
really simple is we're going to go
negate in and now we have our not in
function right there
so we're going to use this
to create our library
so what we're going to do is we're on a
clean R document we're going to go file
new
package new directory and then our
package right here and we're going to
call this analytics because my name's
Dan and it's my talk
um
create package
and then once we create a package you
can already see there's already some
default things they have a Hello print
hello world which is just called hello
so let's just delete that let's remove
it and you can see this is just an R
script so you can have a bunch of
functions that you already have in our
script and just plop it in here and
you're halfway there in this case we're
going to drop our not in function in
here so we're going to do that negate
in
I promise you I'm not this type of slow
at typing
I I go much faster
and then we're just going to do some
house clean let's rename it and again my
talk not yours the Analytics
and then
okay great and then we're going to go to
the top and build
and then install and then install
package
and that's pretty much how you create a
package that's it so if you have a bunch
of functions we're pretty much done and
that's why I'm saying like this could
have been two minutes but we have some
other like things to do that we can add
here
so let's go to the next part
so let's see if this works
so we're going to load the library to
Analytics
and we're going to have attendees we're
going to have Dan Michael or Dan Michael
John Andrew we're going to put that to a
variable and then we're gonna go
attendees in John and then attendees not
in John and as you can see at the bottom
it goes false false true true and it did
the opposite and that's what we want
true true false false so we see that the
not in function works
then let's just move to the next slide
okay and this is a big part documenting
your functions
um and how you're going to do that is
pretty simple
so there's this folder the man folder
right there so we're just going to load
it again
and we're going to go to man and you can
see in there that there's already a
hello file in there and it already has
some documentation so we can take that
use that and replace it with what we
want to add which is going to be the not
in and just like cooking show magic it's
there
and then what's nice about it is if we
just do the help or F1 key
if we do help and then not in you can
see there's some documentation and this
is important because sometimes your
function might be like pretty complex
and you can document it or you might
have to install libraries that are
outside of your function as you can all
document it there so it's easy for a
user to jump in and see what it's doing
and then
oh we already did that okay
so now how do we install this library
and there's going to be three options
for us here we can either do GitHub
public which you know anyone can access
it's not through like crayon which is a
little bit more a little bit more
involved this is just free form
um and that's not behind the firewall
it's just your own GitHub and then
either through the GitHub Enterprise
which that one's going to be through a
firewall so I'll uh teach us how to get
through that securely and only like read
access and not write access to that
Enterprise and then another one you know
a lot of companies don't have GitHub
they have a file director and it's all
shared so you can just save it there and
manage it there and install it there and
you know allow your colleagues to still
access it
so install it from GitHub public is just
this you know install package Dev tools
call that Library
and then install GitHub the developer
name and package name
and so in this example install GitHub
dk5005 and then slash analytics and
that's it and when you install it it'll
just look like a normal installation
and this one's going to be a little bit
more steps but it's not going to be that
daunting as it might seem
so installing from GitHub Enterprise
we're going to install this package use
this
and then Library use this and then what
you're going to do is your whatever your
GitHub username is and your email in
this case mine is daffy.doc and it's
daffy.doc at funnydocs.com
and you're going to create GitHub token
so what's happening here it's going to
use that git config cric GitHub token is
going to use that configuration to then
open up a web browser and then you'll
log into your GitHub and it will bring
you to
this page
and here we're just we would just uh
re-title it you know you have notes you
know this is the analytic package
um and then you can set an expiration
you know you might want to set this as
90 days for security purposes if you're
Ultra conservative or if you just never
want it to expire and then there's
pre-settings here that you can adjust
but a lot of this is just going to be
read only so it won't let you like write
directly against it and like upset your
GitHub
um you don't want your company to be mad
at you
and then where it's going to take you
once you scroll down you hit yes it's
going to take you to here I blurred out
this token I probably didn't have to
because I deleted it afterwards but it's
going to give you a token where like the
blurry line is and you're going to copy
that token and make sure to put it like
in a shared password of some sort you
know keep track of it it's no problem
you can recreate this process and have a
token if you needed to
and then you would just do this just
like before install packages Dev tool
Dev tool install GitHub and then your
company name and then analytics and then
whatever it is that is on the main
branch
and then you put your token in there run
that and it would install that package
so then installing from a file directory
is much simpler than that
all you're going to do is go
use this right here in the dev tools go
install and then you put the file
directory in there and ironically it is
put into a GitHub folder for you then to
download it from a directory
but yes you just do that and then you
can see if we call the library the
analytics it's in and then you have
access to it
so I know like the not in function is
like probably not that exciting in a
function to use so I wanted to kind of
give some examples of some use case that
we use it over at CustomInk connecting
to a SQL database you know I think maybe
just me I go online and I find this all
the time and this is from the r Studio
website is this right here this whole
credentials this is like 12 line of
codes I have no reason why I ever want
to remember this I don't ever want to
remember this and so I created a
function called inkbase CustomInk likes
to Brand everything our mascot is called
Inky so databases are ink bases and so
created a function Inc base
and then what we can do
and then set up some documentation and
here you can see like how do you you
know what do you need you need to
install the package key ring the library
is key ring and then how would you set
that up you go key set so what's the
service that you're using what's your
username you know it would pop up and
give you a password that you put in
there that it secures and so it has like
some setup in the documentation for new
users who have not connected to a single
database
and then another thing that I like is
get SQL
um
just like you know when you go read
underscore CSV this is the same thing I
like to code in a different IDE for SQL
and then save it down rather than having
maybe like 100 lines of a SQL statement
or a thousand lines of the SQL statement
in R I'd rather have it in a different
file and then call that file read it in
and then run that query
and so I created this function which is
like a get SQL
and it's just like takes in the SQL file
and just takes it as a text file
and so
um
yeah so you can see here you know we're
using
um this is no longer our markdown a qmd
file and so I'm going uh ink base for
the function I bring in R postgres SQL
and then I come over here and I go okay
I want to pull in order so I go to this
orders.sql file which is on the right
side right there I pull it in and then I
you know put my connection in there
which is this redshift connection orders
and then pull in the data and I can see
that the data is up there at the top
right
of r
and then another one that I like is
um I love data tables when you put them
in like our markdown files because then
it allows users you have visualizations
and then what's the data behind those
visualizations but one thing that I want
users to be able to do once I give them
my R markdown file is I want them to
have the ability to copy it or download
it as a CSV so maybe they can do their
own visualizations because maybe they
have some other additional analytics
they want to do on their side
and again like I would have to write all
of that stuff which I have no intention
to try to remember and so I created a
function where you can just you know it
has copy CSV and then the length menu
you can just enter it in there you know
for the y1 you can say hey I want to be
10 page or 10 rows long 15 25 whatever
you want
and that looks like this where you have
the copy and then CSV at the top rather
than having to remember all that I can
just call that function
and that is the end of my talk if you're
going to see this this is going to be on
the r Studio GitHub page it's not up
there now but I'll put this up there
[Applause]